foreign
hey you guys time once again for
flickers of fear I know several of you
guys have been waiting for this one I
was actually going to do this one later
on in the month but then I was talking
to a friend of mine when I was out of
the club the other day and uh you know
he's a big horror movie fan too so he's
always like we're always giving each
other recommendations and he was like oh
you should watch the new Hellraiser you
know you'd probably really like it so I
was like all right why not and a couple
people a couple you guys like asked
about it too so I said what the [ __ ]
I'll you know push it up into the uh
into the schedule and uh have a look at
it so uh so I'm coming at this like I'm
a big Clive Barker fan like I'm a big
fan of his fiction and I've actually
read most of his stuff not all of it but
a pretty significant portion of his
novels and stuff that I have read them
um but I find that most film adaptations
of his books or stories really fall
pretty short of these kind of
Fantastical grotesqueries that he like
puts out in his in his work there are
exceptions to that obviously 1992's
Candyman was really really good I love
that movie and I actually have a soft
spot for the Midnight Meat Train uh from
2008 I thought that was a really really
good adaptation of one of his short
stories uh so those are like rare
exceptions and obviously 1987's
excellent Hellraiser which was actually
directed by Clive Barker himself uh was
also really really good and that was
actually based on a novella that he had
written in 1986 called the Hellbound
heart now while I love the first
Hellraiser movie and Hellraiser 2
Hellbound is actually pretty damn good
too if you haven't seen it it's not as
good as the first one but it's like
pretty [ __ ] decent I never really got
into it as a franchise and I don't think
I bothered to watch any of the movies
past the second one I might have seen
the third one but I don't really like
remember anything about it so it didn't
really make an impression now from
everything I've heard about the sequels
uh I was probably wise to just kind of
jump off that drain because I didn't
even know this until today but the
original Hellraiser movie got nine count
them nine sequels many of which were
made they were just kind of like cash
grab type stuff to the only reason they
made them was so they could retain the
rights to the original Ip so they just
had to like put out a new Hellraiser
movie
every so often just so they could keep
their hands on the rights like the
production company or however that works
um I think too there's at least from
what I could determine after 1996's
Hellraiser bloodline the movies I don't
think they were even originally written
or intended as Hellraiser movies anymore
basically like the production company or
the filmmakers or whatever would just
take like some random horror script that
was laying around uh wedge Pinhead in
there call it Hellraiser colon whatever
and just call it a day you know what I
mean uh matter of fact the most recent
Hellraiser sequels uh which was 2011's
Hellraiser Revelations and 2018's
Hellraiser judgment didn't even have
Doug Bradley in them and I'm actually
surprised that Doug Bradley was in eight
of the things because I didn't even like
[ __ ] realize that he was in that many
but even after but after like 2011 he's
like yeah about uh you know I think I've
done but props to him he's amazing and
of course he originated that character
and it's just like such a great
character and he's so associated with it
but I haven't seen like the last two
that he weren't that he wasn't in but
I've seen stills from it and the Pinhead
in that looks really really uh dorky
looks really goofy so I don't you know
no no shade on the actor or anything
like that and I don't know maybe it's
maybe it's fine but I don't know the
Stills look like pretty it is like the
makeup is bad too like you can tell like
it's really really cheap so you know
there's that so what I'm trying to get
at I guess is that the Hellraiser
franchise has been ailing for quite a
while and so it seemed kind of like ripe
for reimagining now Clive Barker matter
of fact had apparently been thinking
about remaking the original film as
early as 2006 but for various reasons
nothing concrete really happened with it
until 2019 when Spyglass Media Group uh
got the rights to it and they got the
screenwriters slash producer David S
goyer on board now he's done a lot of um
he's like I said mostly a screenwriter
so he's done a lot of
um you know superhero type films like
Batman versus Superman I think he did
like a bunch of those type ones but he
also wrote The Blade trilogy and uh
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
so probably like his best stuff there so
he came on board as a producer and the
script for this new Hellraiser was
written by Ben Collins and Luke
pietrovsky who are the same team I think
I brought them up before when I was
talking about another movie but these
are the same guys that wrote the
screenplays to super dark times which I
reviewed not too long ago and the night
house which I also reviewed not too long
ago uh and this was directed by David
Bruckner who co-directed the signal
which is really good uh the Ritual from
2017 which was also excellent and he
directed The Night house which with
Rebecca Hall which I liked a lot so
after so they got kind of all that
Talent involved and were finally able to
bring a new Hellraiser to Hulu the
streaming service in 2022. so is it any
good you may be asking me surprisingly
yes I liked it quite a bit uh it was
actually much better than I was
expecting I mean I guess I went into it
with low expectations and because my
friend had told me he's like well just
go in he's like don't expect it to be
the same movie as the old one or they
kind of like went a different direction
with it but he's like it's still really
good and it's really worth watching so
that so that's really the only
expectation I had that I said oh this
will be pretty good and it indeed it was
pretty good and like I said better than
I expected now I have seen some reviews
that refer to it as a remake or as
another adaptation of the novella that
is absolutely not accurate uh this new
Hellraiser doesn't follow any of the
characters or any of the plot Beats from
the Hellbound Heart Like You know the
original Novella or the 1987 adaptation
of it this movie as I'm presuming some
of the sequels did because I'm not
really sure because I didn't see any of
them past two and maybe three I'm not
really sure but I don't know what
happened with the mythology past that
point but this actually follows a
different set of characters who stumble
across the iconic look you know
lamarchand uh configuration so
that's really one of the best things I
guess about the whole puzzle box conceit
uh is that this box is always kind of
floating around out there in the world
somewhere and new people are always
either like finding it stumbling across
it accidentally or seeking it out
deliberately like knowing what it can do
so you can do a lot of stuff within
those parameters now this movie does go
lighter on the whole uh Sato masochistic
angle which is understandable because
you know all of that imagery isn't
really that shocking or transgressive as
it absolutely was back in 1987 because
back into 87 when the original
Hellraiser came out nobody had made a
horror movie with that imagery in it
before
um so and obviously but now you know
it's this many years later everybody's
seen that now so it's not like shocking
to anybody anymore so they decided to go
in a different direction with it which
obviously was like the best thing to do
but um I will say this does have a
really good like relatable characters
with some depth to them at least like
the main characters have some depth to
them I really like the really cool uh
updated cenobite looks and also this was
like much gorrier than I was expecting I
don't know why I expected them to like
Tamp down the gore or the body horror
but they actually did like a pretty good
job especially like I think the last uh
bit I don't want to like spoil it
because this is like brand new but but
the last bit if you've seen it you don't
tell the last guy that gets you know
it's it's just really good I really
really like the way that it looks it's
very very visceral and like really cool
so what happens in this movie there's
kind of like an extended prologue I
guess if you want to call it that and
this involves a depraved billionaire
named Roland Voigt and his interactions
with the puzzle box like he knows what
it is and he actually like sought it out
for its intended purpose so there's that
so after that we kind of get into the
main part of the story
so our main protagonist is named Riley
and she's played by Odessa azion I guess
I'm pronouncing that correctly
she's a recovering addict and she lives
in an apartment with her brother Matt
and Matt's boyfriend Colin and then they
have another roommate named Nora's they
all like live in this big apartment
together Riley has also been on again
off again seeing this guy like new
boyfriend named Trevor Who Matt has a
bad feeling about
um mainly because uh Riley met him at
one of her 12-step programs and he's
kind of like afraid that she's going to
relapse like with him around you know
what I'm saying but Riley insists that
Trevor's a good guy and she kind of like
resents her brother's interference in
her life I guess I have to say that
Odessa a Zion is absolutely kills it in
this role I kind of feel like in the
context of the story and all of the
baggage that her character has like with
her addiction and she's the way she
comes across it's like you know she's
having a hard time but she does come
across as like kind of selfish or kind
of immature or something like that and
that could very easily make her
character come off as unlikable but I
actually didn't find her unlikable at
all I mean yeah she's [ __ ] up and yes
she has some major issues but to me she
still came across as very like under you
understood like where she was coming
from she still came across as like
endearing and somewhat sympathetic and
she was kind of like I think it was
maybe like her sense of humor uh kind of
endeared me to her as well I did see
some reviews that didn't think she was
all that likable but I don't agree with
that I think she was uh quite likable
even though like I said she was
obviously a very very troubled and
damaged person
um so I just want to like give a shout
out to her because it seemed like that
her performance her acting performance
here was like really really genuine and
really really natural and it really did
help you sell you know it helped you see
her as just like this is a real person
who's you know maybe doing some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] but you know she's a real person
and she's hurting and you kind of like
empathize with her somewhere so Trevor
uh just like Matt suspected of being a
bad influence Trevor convinces Riley oh
they're gonna make some extra cash by
breaking into this big like storage
container one of those big ones that's
like a size of a train car type thing
um now he says that this thing has been
abandoned for a really long time like no
one's coming to get whatever the [ __ ] is
in here you know it's fine now he says
he apparently used to work at this
shipping yard where the container is and
he's like all the shipments that came in
that he saw you know they all had all of
these really expensive objects and
antiques and [ __ ] like that which had
been purchased abroad by like super rich
people and then you know shipped over
here so long story short too late uh
they break into this massive container
and all that's in there is this little
safe like right in the middle
so they managed to bust into the safe
and that is what ends up putting the
faded lamarchand configuration into
their clueless hands now Trevor kind of
shrugs and says well it's got to be
worth something otherwise why would it
be like locked up in here like this so
he tells Riley why don't you hang on to
it I'm gonna like you know talk to my
contacts and stuff like that and see if
I can negotiate some money and we'll
split it Riley meanwhile uh falls off
the wagon and this causes a blistering
argument between her and her brother and
her brother ends up like kicking her out
of the apartment apparently she hadn't
been paying the rent to like he's been
covering her ass for like several months
and I guess it's just everything comes
to a head and he just can't take it
anymore he's like just get the [ __ ] out
get you know get your [ __ ] and get out
of here
so uh she kind of goes on a little bit
of a downward spiral it gets completely
[ __ ] up on booze and some pills that
she had left over I'm not sure what
exactly what they were uh while she's
doing that she inadvertently makes the
puzzle box like she's kind of [ __ ]
around with it and it moves into one of
its other configurations and she starts
freaking out as she gets her first
glance of the cenobite
now because she's so wasted though she
isn't entirely sure if what she's seeing
is real I mean obviously she's like oh
this is like some potent [ __ ] you know
what I mean I'm seeing like [ __ ] Sato
masochistic rape demons or whatever also
because she tries to like tell her uh
you know friends about it and they all
kind of think yeah we've been down this
road before that's just like the drugs
and booze talking like you're just
hallucinating yada yada so no one
believes her at first not long after
this though uh the reality of the
situation becomes all too evident after
Riley's brother Matt gets taken by the
cenobites in one particular uh scene and
so the rest of the movie is basically
Riley going on this frantic journey of
Discovery trying to figure out where did
this box come from who owned it before
like what does it do uh all this other
kind of stuff hoping that she can use
this knowledge to bring her brother back
from wherever the [ __ ] you know whatever
hell Dimension he got like sucked into
so as I said this movie is actually more
of its own story taking place inside the
Hellraiser Universe rather than a direct
adaptation of the novella or a remake of
the 1987 film so I think you could I
mean you could technically say it was a
sequel like I said I didn't really see
any of the later sequels so I don't
really know how that mythology like
developed and I don't know if this is
like a complete reboot or it's just like
a complete side mission or I'm not
really sure you could totally see it as
a sequel though but it is absolutely not
an adaptation of the Hellbound heart the
story is completely different none of
the characters are the same so just
don't go into it expecting that same
plot again and honestly like I said I
think this was probably the best
approach for updating the franchise
because I mean the mythology surrounding
the puzzle box and the cenobites is
complex enough that it can Encompass
lots of new stories within that same
framework
um I liked too they there was a
connection made between Riley's
struggles with her addiction you know
with drugs and booze or whatever and the
obsessive sensation seeking of people
that coveted the box like the
billionaire
um I really liked that connection and
it's very well done I did not find it
heavy-handed at all
um you know your mileage may vary on
that it's so I mean to me it's like the
metaphor was just like there if you
wanted to explore it but if you didn't
want to you didn't have to you know what
I mean it wasn't too like in your face
with it at least I didn't find it that I
also want to give a particular shout out
to Jamie Clayton who is the new
iteration of Pinhead now here in the
movies just Pinhead is just called the
hell priest which is more in keeping
with the spirit of the original Source
material in the original movie which
obviously never referred to the
character as the Pinhead nickname
because that was just like a nickname
that he got later on it's not called
that like in any of the stories or
anything so uh Jamie Clayton wisely
chose not to try to fill Doug Bradley's
substantial shoes and kind of like puts
her own spin on the character so her
interpretation of it is a lot more alien
is a lot more aloof is a lot more still
he's just a very otherworldly and I kind
of liked that uh kind of take on the
character uh the other Santa bites look
pretty cool too and I like that the
creature designs that they did
essentially have the cenobites like
wearing outfits kind of that are made
out of their own skin and viscera like
it looks like they've been like cut into
strips and like made into like which I
thought was like really cool like a
really good idea
um rather than you know the original
1987 movie that had them dressed like in
kind of bondage gear leather and bondage
vinyl bondage gear so I like that they
just did it with their skin so it looked
like their flesh is all flayed and [ __ ]
like that like they're not even wearing
clothes but it's just yeah I just
thought that was like a cool idea the
movie is a little bit dark so I kind of
wish that it had been like a little
because I think I saw like a lot of
reviewers like saying how murky it was I
didn't find it that dark but I do kind
of wish they had lightened it up
slightly just so you could see uh
because the center bite designs were so
cool and I kind of wish that they would
have had it a little bit lighter so you
could like see the detail in them a
little bit more but I mean just from
looking at them even though it was kind
of dark like you could still tell that
they looked really rad and really other
than that the only minor criticisms um
that I could give of the film is it's a
slightly slightly long I mean it's like
it's almost exactly two hours which you
know it's just like a touchdown I didn't
feel like it dragged or anything like
that but it probably didn't need to be
that long and the fact that some of the
side characters like particularly Colin
and Nora are kind of like underdeveloped
like they don't really spend enough time
with them
um but neither of those nitpicks are
really deal breakers for me it's not
really that big a deal
um I will say too that this version of
Hellraiser is much slicker than the kind
of more CD 80s version but that didn't
really bother me all that much as you
either I mean as I mentioned before the
cultural context in which the original
came out uh you know the culture has
changed so much since that time so like
the same qualities that made that like
so like I said like CD and underground
and like [ __ ] up and you know and
gritty and everything like that like it
doesn't really play the same nowadays
just because the cultural is so
different than it was in 1987. so you
know they they changed it they went with
that direction and I think that was like
the right choice to make
um now while this movie isn't brilliant
it's not a masterpiece or anything like
that but I found it like a really
compelling really entertaining and very
respectful entry you can tell that the
people that made this like really care
about this franchise and really care
about these characters and really wanted
to do something substantive
um you know and honestly like you can't
[ __ ] on it too much because the [ __ ]
because all the other sequels of it have
as far as I've heard are like terrible
and just like cheap cash grabs so it's
nice to see a movie that was obviously
made with care and with love for the
source material and that does absolutely
come through in this movie so you know
it has also has like really really
memorable imagery I really particularly
liked like the house with the big cage
thing on the outside like if you've seen
it you know what I'm talking about and I
really like a lot of the gore like I
said it was like really creative
particularly like the last scene with
the flaying I thought that was like
really really cool and really well done
it's like really icky and like you could
really kind of feel it and I thought
that was really well done it's probably
CGI but it's really really good CGI I
don't know maybe it was practical
effects I kind of feel like it was CGI
but it doesn't look like bad CGI but
yeah so let me know what you guys
thought about the new Hellraiser in the
comments because I've been seeing it
seems kind of like a lot of people
really really didn't like it all that
much some people I haven't seen anybody
like love it love it but a lot of people
were like oh hey that was like pretty
good which is which is is where I'm at
like I don't know if I loved it but it
was pretty damn good and it was like way
better than I was expecting it to be but
I have seen like some reviewers that
just that didn't like it for one reason
or another so I'm kind of curious as to
what you guys thought about it if you
saw it so let me know in the comments
and that'll do it for this flickers of
fear I'll see you guys again on the next
one